este voto la exdiputada anti chavista
María Corina Machado está inhabilitada
por 15 años para competir por un cargo
de elección popular así lo ratificó la
contraloría general de Venezuela la
decisión tendrá que ver con el respaldo
de Machado a las sanciones impuestas por
Estados Unidos contra el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro y su apoyo a Juan guaidó
La líder es hoy una de las favoritas de
Cara a las elecciones primarias de la
oposición
en administración que pretenden
[Aplausos]
pero la contraloría no es Clara sobre
desde y hasta cuándo rige la sanción en
2015 el mismo evento aplicó una sanción
por un año contra Machado cuando iba a
presentarse a las elecciones
parlamentarias a comienzos de 2023 la
oposición venezolana convocó a
elecciones el 22 de octubre para elegir
al candidato que enfrentaría a maduro en
las presidenciales de 2024 Machado
reafirmó su precandidatura y no será la
única que compita bajo una sanción
Enrique capriles y Freddy superlano
recibieron acciones similares en el
pasado
de apéndice que es la contraloría del
estado que la usan como un un órgano
para perseguir para inhabilitar
Sencillamente todos están al margen de
la ley ninguno goza de legitimidad y de
este régimen que no busca más que en su
estado de pánico a callar la decisión de
un pueblo que ha decidido ser libre
Estados Unidos condenó la decisión de la
contraloría mientras que la oea aseguró
que el fallo es arbitrario y que el
gobierno de maduro utiliza los
mecanismos de inhabilidad para aferrarse
al poder